19:39 in Eastern Europe is getting a bit
nervous there were two very good reasons
for this to the East's at the Union of
Soviet Socialist Republics led by Josef
Stalin who had been eyeing up his
neighbor's territories for a while now
to the west was the Third Reich under a
certain Adolphe Hitler who also had some
expansionist ideas as demonstrated by
his previous annexations of both Austria
and Czechoslovakia
fortunately for Eastern Europe the two
powers flanking them despised each other
and were opposed in nearly all things
this meant that the countries between
them could use the threat of alliances
to deter aggression from either of
course ideology play second fiddle to
pragmatism and Stalin was eager to
improve relations with Germany so much
so that Stalin fired his Jewish foreign
minister Maxim Litvinov and replaced him
with the atra Slav Molotov in order to
appease Hitler in August Hitler sent his
foreign minister yo Akeem von Ribbentrop
to Moscow to negotiate a Treaty of
mutual benefit in the end the USSR and
the Third Reich agreed on a
non-aggression pact the Molotov
Ribbentrop pact they agreed not to help
each other's enemies and also made a
secret agreement to create their own
spheres of influence in Eastern Europe
the map was to go from this to this and
in case you're wondering the states
involved weren't to be asked what they
wanted on the 1st of September nine days
after signing the agreement Hitler
invaded Poland beginning World War two
on the 17th the Soviets join them and
invaded from the east and Poland was
soon after conquered in later September
both sides sat down to determine what
the formal borders between their
countries would be the Germans had
conquered much of Poland quicker than
they had anticipated in return for them
keeping more of Poland they offered the
USSR Lithuania which Stalin agreed to
this left him free over the next year to
demand his neighbor's territories or in
the case of the Baltics their entire
Nations all of which he achieved with
only the threat of military action with
the exception of Finland whom Stalin
attempted to bully into submission
attempted being the operative word there
both signatories were keen on this deal
for many reasons for Germany it's
ensured that it wouldn't have to fight a
two-front war for the USSR the Molotov
Ribbentrop pact Rove a wedge between
Germany Japan meaning they also wouldn't
have to worry about a two-front war
another important benefit was that it
allowed Stalin free rein in Eastern
Europe to expand Soviet borders the most
important benefit for the USSR was of
course the guarantee that Germany
wouldn't invade it I hope you enjoyed
this episode and thank you for watching
and a special thanks to all of these
patrons you see on screen for their
generosity in supporting
show and a particularly special thanks
to James Bissonnette party boy Co
Michael Reynolds Gustav Swan
Winston Cawood Skye Chappell Adam Harvey
Gable airy and as ARCA Flash
you